hello everyone and welcome to the other
really awesome game from the semi-final
match of the video grand prix currently
being played in belgrade it's anish
geary versus dmitry andreikin and first
we covered the game between uh rapper
and mvl you've seen that one ended very
very quickly this one i did not end very
quickly or rather it did but it could
have ended even quicker
uh but you guys will have to help out
with this one so it's one of those games
that you
don't believe what's actually in the
game until you see it and then you're
like well of course there's that but
it's easier if i just show you so anish
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 we have c5 and draken goes for the
sicilian defense knight f3 e6 and now
not the open sicilian or anything like
bishop to b5 or something like that but
rather b3 so this is the vesterinan
attack and it's not a very very common
practice so b6 andreikin also wants the
fiance to his light square bishop we
have bishop to b2 bishop to b7 and
knight to c3 so defending our e for pawn
while continuing development knight to
f6 putting more pressure on the e4 pawn
so you can see uh as white did not go
for the open sicilian he uh
goes for g3 think carrying the bishop
black you get some very natural ideas of
how to develop his pieces so here we
have e5 grabbing more space challenging
the knight knight to e4 and here we have
a trade knight captures bishop captures
and now developing the queen with an
attack on the bishop so bishop moves
bishop to b7 and now there is a game
where queen to e3 was played but here
anish plays h4 and it is now already as
of move 9 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how andreikin
continues knight to c6
again this knight can always come to
d4 for example if you're you're gonna
develop the queen on c7 maybe castle
queen side uh click king to b8 put the
rook on c8 or maybe just even put the
rook and c8 queen on c7 you can see how
the knight coming to d4 might be useful
because if let's say knight captures
we're going to capture with the pawn
we're going to open up our c file if
white casts queen side good things might
happen for black so here anish continues
in the style of the of the modern uh
neural network engines he plays h5 wants
to get that pawn all the way to h6 and
now andreikin says i don't believe for a
second in what you're doing on the king
side it's only move 10 your pawn is
already on h5 i'm just going to go
knight b4 and now i'm threatening knight
captures on c2 which wins the exchange
and also you can't castle queen side
because your a2 pawn will fall so how do
you defend this well anis just plays d3
you could also strike with the d4 but
anisha wants to keep the position closed
for now the queen now nicely defends the
c2 pawn and here andreikin still not
really interested in what anish is doing
on the king side continues with b5 now
the pawn might come to c4 open up the
position and we could have a very open
game so a3 kicking away the knight
knight back to c6 uh and now queen to d2
it makes sense because the knight can
come at d4 at any point then the queen
will be under attack maybe you're gonna
have to react by capturing the knight
here and the queen on e2 isn't really
covering much territory the queen on d2
covers a lot of territory and also makes
room for the bishop to jump into the
game if needed so here rook the c8 a
very natural square for the black rook
to be developed also in the future
something like knight to a5 c4 might
come you want to break open the position
the rook will be very useful here uh and
anish goes rook to h3 uh now look at
this the the rook can come to g3 put
pressure on g7 the knight can come to g5
the bishop controlling this diagonal so
anish is shifting all of his attention
to the king's side we have queen to c7
and reikin still not interested in what
this queen side thing is
and anish now just castles queen side
and now we have this very very cool
position the black king is still in the
center of the board which isn't really
odd as the sicilian was played so how
can black continue here well here andre
can goes knight to a5 he wants to put
more pressure on that c4 square another
way of doing things is to just play
knight to d4 you already have a rook on
c8 queen on c7 so you know the knight is
beautifully placed on d4 and if white
ever captures it then you get to open up
the c file and this will of course be
great for you in the long run uh d4 pawn
is not up for grabs because the a3 pawn
would be hanging so here let's say f4 we
just defend the pawn here and the game
continues and black has a very very uh
good position however here at night the
a5 was played and now the game continues
in a completely different manner we have
knights the g5 now uh
well stirring a lot of trouble here the
knight might be interested in coming to
e4 if challenged and here if you go to
c4 right away it's not really all that
great we can just capture once and play
b4 and then the knight has to move and
nothing really fun happening here or you
don't move the knight you challenge
white's knight which is similar to what
actually happened in the game so after
knight g5 bishop to e7 uh putting
pressure on the knight and then now
comes rook the g3 sonic still continuing
with his uh
uh
onslaught of the of the king side and
now we have c4
uh here maybe h6 is the way to go
because then knight has to go back for
example knight e4 bishop captures d
captures you nicely double whites uh e
pawn and now you strike with c4 and this
is a little bit different than what
happened in the game here and they can
strike with c4 right away and now we
have d captures in c for b captures in
c4 and b4 and now uh how do you how do
you continue here you know that if
knight comes to c6 then the c4 pawn is
just free so what do you do uh or or
rather even after knights to c6 we could
go for h6 this is um this could be even
more interesting and now black's pretty
much busted uh for example bishop
captures on g5 we're going to play queen
captures uh and after captures here
we're going to play queen here attack
the rogue one through ghost f8 now we
play b5 and the black is just out of any
any good moves if 97 we play a4 and
defend our b5 pawn open up the a3
square for our bishop to grab hold of
this diagonal and this will not end well
for black so this is why
moving the knight isn't really an option
so here andre can place h6 and this is
where the fun really starts this is
where the game can go really really good
for for white or it can go really really
good for black or it can continue uh in
many different ways all depending on
what you play so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
strongest winning move for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations i'm always
thinking that the knight might have to
go back at some point and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
knight captures on f7 is what anish
played but this is not the movie that
we're looking for but still
congratulations as you've played the
move that a very strong grandmaster
played the actual move that wins the
game is knight to h3 and this is looking
very odd i mean why would knight to h3
win the game it's such a silly square
for the knight
the point of knight to the h3 is that
black is without any moves here the
knight on a5 is hanging and the pawn on
g7 is hanging plus if the knight moves
then the pawn on c4 is hanging and once
you combine all of that there's simply
not all that much black can do just to
give you an example of course we're
going to move the knight otherwise we're
just down a piece we're going to capture
on c4 and now how do you react to this
pawn being attacked well uh let's say
your castle if your castle queen
captures on h6 and it's game over for
black that's just it uh so we're not
playing that you could try rook to g8 to
defend pawn uh also not all that great
once f4 is played uh what move is there
for black to play if you can even spot
one let's say you try a5 you want to
bust open the queen side start an attack
we just advance the pawn to b5 if knight
a7 we can shift this rook over to c3 not
much for for black to do here
so that's that's what what happens after
bishop captures on c4 so what you could
do is maybe capture with the knight on
e5 and it seems like okay we win this
pawn now it's going to be good for us
the problem is white can simply capture
that and after queen captures an e5 we
can play queen captures on d7 once the
king moves we're gonna capture on b7
attack the rook here and of course now
you might think well of course rook
captures in c4 wins the piece back but
queen e8 and you get checkmated there's
no way out for black once you give up
all of the pieces then it's just a nice
queen captures on the eight checkmate uh
or if you don't capture the uh the
bishop on c4 you might think oh but
there's queen to a1 check surely white
cannot allow this
well in fact white can allow this queen
a1 check king to d2 let's say you try
queen d4 check uh just bishop d3 let's
say queen c3 check you go king e2 queen
to e5 king f1 and the king is perfectly
safe on f1 white is up a piece in a
completely winning position you've
shifted your your
king that castle queen side to now a
king and that's castled king side and
safely at that and there's really not
all that much for black to do here so
here after this h6 move uh just knight
the h3 and as the title suggests
sometimes you just have to relax a
little bit uh and you know good things
will happen as black is completely
busted in this position but it's of
course incredibly difficult to spot
something like this in an actual game uh
because everything is hanging you have
so many ideas uh do do capture here do
you go do you go back how do you exploit
the the d7 pawn being weak what's up
with the knight on a5 uh many many
things to consider and anish goes for
knight captures on f7 which is not a bad
move of course it's a good move uh it's
not just uh as good as knight to h3 so
here king captures on f7 we have to play
this
and then now comes b captures on a5 and
this is also not an easy decision for
anish because how do you decide between
this this and queen captures on d7 uh to
show you what happens after queen
captures on d7 black captures the rook
captures and now again you can't move
the knight because the bishop hangs on
b7 so here you might play rook h to d8
you want to force a white to make a
decision but now white will happily go
after rook captures on e7 give up the
rook for for bishop and knight and after
king captures b captures on a5 and now
you have this position uh for example
king to f8 we have to guard our g7 pawn
and now let's say bishop to c3 we
prevent the pawn from being pushed here
you get this position where black is up
the exchange however white has the very
strong bishop pair you could play rook
to g4 go after the c4 pawn the bishop
here nicely guards everything pretty
much and it's not going to be easy to
utilize the rook pair as much as it will
uh to utilize the the power of the
bishop pair also the e6 pawn is very
weak
so it would it would make sense to play
something like this for white but not an
easy decision anish makes this decision
b captures on a5 and still it's very
very interesting now bishop to d5 black
consolidates a little bit and now we
have queen to f4 with check king to g8
king the e8 um a little bit safer but
then again you are um bringing your king
to the to the center of the board
however even just by looking at it the
king appears to be safer on the under in
the middle of the board than on the king
side here after king to g8 you are
blocking your rook from entering the
game and that's never a good thing
uh but still it's very hard for white to
exploit this let's say you play queen g4
which seems to be the best move uh how
are you defending this uh your g7 pawn
is hanging this is the threat of
checkmate so of course we have to play
rook to h7 to defend this now this is an
even sillier square for the rook but now
it it's sort of impossible to find the
move for white here but not really if
you find rook to d4 then it all makes
sense it's such a such a wonderful move
uh
just asking what do you what do you play
here with black point is that if e5 is
captured then okay you've grabbed the
pawn but you've also opened up this
diagonal for the white bishop we're just
going to play f4 once the queen moves we
can play rook to d2 now open up this
diagonal now we threaten to capture on
g7 also you don't have to worry about
this because the rook is also guarding
the a3 pawn so let's say bishop f8
defending this now bishop to e5 and it's
again a very very very powerful position
for white that only white can win uh
black can never win this but it's of
course incredibly tricky anish goes for
a different line it's also a super
tricky line and a very enjoyable one
rook captures on d5 where if the rook is
captured black just falls apart if he
captures on the e5 then comes rook
captures on g7 with check and you are
getting checkmated king captures you
open up a discovery here with check so
uh what do you do here you could move
the king let's say king g8 now you get
checkmated or you could try something
like c3 you block the check but then
just queen to f7 is checkmate of course
uh the dh8 and h6 squares are not
available to the black king so instead
after rook captures on d5 it seems like
black is completely busted probably one
anish went for this instead of a line
like rook to d4 but there is bishop to
g5 and this saves the game for andreikin
now the queen is hanging you have to
give up the rook here rook captures and
g5 h captures on g5 and now how do you
continue the queen hanging uh and the
rook hanging what do you play uh two
options really you could move the queen
or you could capture on c4 uh if you
capture on c4 then we trade down
captures captures we're going to capture
uh not on c4 we're going to capture the
rook of course with e captures on d5
bishop captures with king of f8 and now
bishop to d4 preventing rook to c5 and
uh well it's a bishop pair against the
rook pair but white is up three pawns so
this will be
incredibly difficult for for black to
play uh notice you still can't activate
the rook for example by capturing on h5
because if white captures an a7 it's
pretty much game over you know that once
you put those bishops on let's say b6
and b7 then all of these squares are
controlled and you can just start
pushing your pass pawn it will be
impossible for black to stop this so
this is one way to go about it the other
one is what anish played queen to d4
giving up the rook this way e captures
on the e5 queen captures as the black
king is wide open so makes sense you
still want to keep the queens on the
board king the f8 and now bishop to d4
not allowing a move like c3 to trap the
bishop and now andre can just place
queen to c6 he says all right let's
trade queens i've had just about enough
of this game
and there really isn't a a a way to
avoid this because the queen cannot go
here cannot go in this direction
so all the squares where you go to will
uh just allow black to trade queen so
here best is just a trade right away
queen captures rook captures and now the
ship to eq regarding the the h5 pawn
first you could also capture on a7 but
now the position is a little bit
different
as the pawn is still on c4 defended so
you do not have access to the queen side
with a light square bishop so here we
have a6 not allowing bishop capture
spawn now king d2 we have to bring our
king to c3 to prevent this pawn from
being pushed we have king the e7 finally
allowing the rook to enter the game king
to c3 and now rook to b8 here we have a4
not allowing any rook to b5 ideas but
still now there really aren't all that
many squares for the rooks to use
rook the b1 looks nice but now bishop to
f3 and now everything is guarded here
there is nothing for the black rooks to
attack absolutely everything is guarded
and of course if you play something like
or rather it was in this position that
the players agreed to a draw as there is
pretty much nothing to try here uh also
they're very low on on time anish has
some three minutes on the clock and they
can have two minutes on the clock so it
would be um well maybe best to just uh
to you know wait for tomorrow's game and
see see who who will do better there
because uh seven more moves until time
control anything can go wrong for either
player maybe rook to a1 seems a little
bit interesting going after this but
then the rook just hangs on c6 so
there's really not all that much you can
do here
uh so yeah
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
it always when uh in a critical
situation maybe you know uh
it's of course easier said than done but
sometimes it's best to just relax here
once you see it knight to h3 after h6
knight to h3 then you can see that black
has no moves and uh it's just a
terrible position black got himself into
and by forcing this knight captures on
f7 you've actually allowed black to
to even have moves uh otherwise black
doesn't have any moves uh so yeah maybe
something that we can take uh from this
game and maybe try and apply in in your
own future games
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh we're continuing today
with round two of the video grand prix
semifinals uh i would like to thank
zoolong closebox.com uh lucas del cartes
jonathan lay and dave austin for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
grand prix
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day